All right, let's begin with an overview of ICV effects.
So when we talk about ICV effects,
it actually falls under an umbrella term
called virtual production.
And virtual production has a number
of different classifications that we should discuss.
Number one, visualization.
This is basically what we originally considered
pre-visualization, and it includes a number
of various forms of 3D pre-visualization
and virtual scouting.
A lot of these tools have basically evolved
to be part of this process,
and they're included under the entire term
of virtual production.
Secondly, there's performance capture,
and this again, another broad term,
it includes things like standard mocap,
performance capture in general,
facial capture, and even keyframe animation.
Everything needs to have some sort of source
for performance.
Then we move on to traditional hybridized
VFX production.
Now this is getting into a much larger space.
This is the classic green screen
along with tracking markers that is used
to construct various VFX shots,
typically building out various layers
and bringing things together in comp
at a post-production facility.
And then finally, we have in-camera visual effects.
And it's this particular category
that we want to talk about today.
This is the whole LED wall,
virtual production-based process
in which you're filming everything through the camera
along with what you're seeing behind
the actual foreground actor on an LED wall.
But there are a number of different project types
that we usually refer to,
and they are basically fully animated production.
This is a form of virtual production.
Obviously everything is computer generated and in CG.
There's a live action equivalent, of course,
where we're shooting live action content
and we're using the virtual production
and VFX process in order to comp in various backgrounds,
matte extensions and set extensions
and other types of effects.
And then finally, the whole CG live action hybrid,
we're bringing it all together on the stage
in-camera visual effects in hand.
In order to get a better appreciation
as to how in-camera visual effects developed,
we're gonna look at some historical context.
And this is always something that's of interest
to a lot of people,
but ICV effects just didn't spontaneously appear.
It actually has a number of different forerunners to it.
So let's first talk about the Pepper's ghost technique.
This is basically, it's an optical illusion.
It was designed to reflect a performance on a pane of glass
that was between the performer and the actual audience.
And this was popularized by Disney
for its haunted mansion ride.
And it's actually been used today at current modern times,
particularly for producing like a form of hologram
of famous actors like Michael Jackson or Tupac.
There was a number of them that have used this technique.
Next, we'll talk about rear screen projection.
Now, this is kind of a classic,
and it's usually associated with a lot of people
who consider these films to be like B movies nowadays,
but this was really a simple technique.
It was basically combining a projected
pre-filmed reversed background,
and it was projected onto a screen
so that you'd have a central foreground actor
and the rear screen behind him.
This technique was perfected pretty much,
its highest point was 2001, A Space Odyssey.
They used it there,
but it was used on an array of different films
throughout the 1930s, all the way up to the 1970s.
Next, we have front screen projection.
Now, this is basically,
it's a derivative of rear screen projection,
where again, that pre-filmed content
was composited behind the actor,
but the way that the image was brought and projected
was a little bit of a trick.
They usually typically use like a prism
or some sort of beam splitter
in order to project the image
from the front of the screen
rather than from the back of the screen.
And this afforded us some extra benefits.
Number one, the image was brighter
and the colors were more saturated.
And this basically is, again,
still being used today.
There's been a number of modern productions
that have used this,
like Oblivion used front screen projection
for a number of its visual effects shots,
but it's films that you normally saw
during the 80s, 90s and early 2000s.
Let's take a look at our next one, which was dynamation.
Now, this is a Ray Harryhausen technique
that is a combination of different things.
It's basically combining stop motion animation
on one plane,
along with a rear projected screen on another plane,
and then a foreground matte.
And this is kind of a very interesting precursor
to a number of different techniques
used in animation as well.
I list it within virtual production
as a forerunner for all of this
because it is really forward-thinking
in a lot of different ways.
Next is the sodium vapor process.
Now, this process utilizes
a photochemical approach to filmmaking,
where it combines actors and backgrounds together.
This originated in the 1950s,
and it was heavily utilized by Walt Disney again,
and they called it yellow screening.
And this utilizes basically really powerful
sodium vapor lights
that have a specific wavelength and cast,
and a camera that, again, utilizing a beam splitter,
this prism exposed two different,
basically separate films.
And one would be the beauty pass in full color,
and the other would basically be a black and white matte pass
that was used to help with bringing the composite together.
This was the first precursor
to the blue screening techniques,
which we see next, blue chroma key.
This was designed after the traveling matte technique
was perfected and developed by RKO Pictures,
Radio Pictures in the 1930s.
Blue screen process developed along yellow screening
and used a very similar technique
of combining an optical printer with two projectors
and a camera and a beam splitter
in order to produce these two passes,
one for the beauty pass and one for the matte pass.
This blue screening technique
eventually became the favorite over yellow screening,
and it was used a lot during the early,
or excuse me, the late 20th century.
Blue screening eventually evolved into green screening,
and this is a process that was developed
in the early 1970s by American British television networks
and various newscast centers.
We were starting to see the beginnings
of the microcomputer age,
and this basically assisted and eventually evolved
past the optical printing process
and started to combine, of course,
with computer graphic imagery.
So green was selected over blue
just due to the fact that green was not
as heavily utilized and is not normally found
in typically in the skin of most people.
Green screen was just a better approach for that,
whereas you see that a lot of skin tones
have a lot of blue in it.
So they moved over to green as a better process.
Ultimately, through the use and advancements
of computer graphic and aided imagery,
the green screen technique was combined
with tracking markers where the movement of the camera
could be reverse engineered
and fed into various different compositing programs,
allowing you to basically combine computer graphic animation
along with live action film.
This ultimately gave way and is giving way
to the process that we're talking about today,
which is in-camera visual effects.
Now, this is basically the earliest forerunner to this.
You're probably familiar with it.
It's the Mandalorian.
And this was basically a whole amalgamation of techniques
that are being brought together.
Computer graphic technologies, motion capture,
camera tracking, all of this is combined
with live real-time graphics that are being generated
and put onto an LED wall.
And this is something that we're gonna be talking
about today, what does this LED wall look like,
how it's put together and constructed and so forth.
And this allows, of course,
for any kind of computer-generated imagery
to be placed behind the actor.
And when combined with some mid-ground elements
and some foreground action,
you can construct some very, very believable effects
that can be shot in camera in real time.
And it's really quite an advancement.